nowadays we meet people and the first
thing we do once we go home or turn away
is google them find out one who they are
what they're about do you think it's a
society we will repeal and say I want to
be anonymous I know a lot of what is
online we control we put that in for our
profiles but do you think as a society
we will say I want to be unknown I don't
want to be looked up no I think it's
humans you want to say I matter who i am
and we have so many ways to express
ourselves now and I think that
everyone's just a little kid wanting to
be recognized for who they are and out
of different and how their unique and
you want to connect and they want to be
loved and they want to be a part of
something and I think that's what a lot
of this is about and as we grow older
you know a lot of my film connected
explores that I mean I think you know
we're all connected by our very biology
by history by everything and to think of
ourselves as separate is ridiculous and
I think the notion of privacy is an
illusion ridiculous I think it's very
generational like I just assume anything
I write down will be public that's just
the way I'm like Google owns my gmail
and I tell my team that you know don't
think you're writing anything down that
is not going to be public because it is
and we're living in a very public time
and you know if you want to write in
your journal or there's a course spaces
where you can be private but why are
people so obsessed with privacy I mean
the part where I of course I get
uncomfortable as if corporations could
use your health information to not
provide you health insurance and I of
course do not you know that worries me
and having controls around that but all
in all it's you know in the tech I live
in the Bay Area and there was this huge
pair chamber I can't talk about what I'm
working on everybody was like ND I can't
talk about it so meticulous every dinner
party is most boring dinner parties I
can't talk about
working that and you know I always even
films i'm not even sure what they are i
try to talk to me about some kind of
working it out as i'm talking on today
what are you working on well i'm working
on this cloud filmmaking it even the
very nature of trying to describe it and
share it helps me figure it out so I
think sharing always leads to good
things so I'm not so do people want
privacy the younger and younger you go I
think it's less and less important
you